on
vient juste d'atterrir on a toujours le
feu vert l'opération est en route
on parachute en commande au secret de
robots dans un pays où on n'a absolument
rien à faire c'est sérieux depuis la
seconde ou en latérite
tu la fermes barrez vous aujourd'hui
tous
[Applaudissements]
en avant pour elle
ces gens entrevue faites-les tous
disparaître nous nous voulons aucun
témoin
on a son identité je vous envoie ça un
marine si c'est un déserteur ça pourrait
être un très bon test je me suis dit la
même chose
elle est étudiante en médecine ce sont
tous des médecins ils sont là en mission
humanitaire
allez ça suffit là tu es en train de lui
[ __ ] la trouille et tu me fout la
trouille à moi aussi j'ai pas la
trouille
violent t'attends tu te bats comme havre
à l'homme si tu oses
[Applaudissements]
alors
tu as été fabriqués par les humains pour
infliger la marque aussi le rythme est
différent je suis un homme suis vivant
c'est une machine